as we think about the 2018 in the 2020
elections a really relevant question is
whether Democrats will be able to take
advantage of the disaster sort of known
to us as Donald Trump and do well in the
2018 midterms and ultimately in the 2020
election and we don't really know right
I mean at the national level the special
elections have not gone particularly
well for Democrats since November of
2016 but there is one statistic that
maybe points to the anti Republican
undertone of the last six months at the
state level in 2017 so far Democrats
have taken seven seats from Republicans
while Republicans on the other hand have
not taken any state legislative seats
from Democrats and most recently earlier
this week Tuesday night Democrats
flipped to more Republican held seats
one is in New Hampshire one in Oklahoma
and those were big Trump districts back
in November and there's another
interesting number which is that out of
35 races at the state and congressional
level the Democratic candidate has done
better than Hillary Clinton in the same
districts in November in 26 of those in
26 of 35 of these races the Democratic
candidate got more support on a
percentage basis lower turnout but on a
percentage basis then Hillary Clinton in
November now they still lost in some of
those districts right so they might have
outperformed Hillary Clinton's November
performance but still ultimately lost to
a Republican but that's okay right we're
looking at trends and a legitimate
question is how much do state-level
races correlate with what is or might
happen at the national level next
November or two years after that it's
not really clear but still these are
interesting indicators to look at
another one is that Republicans have
quite a few resigning and retiring seats
resigning and retiring politicians I
guess we would call it leaving open
House seats for 2018 that number is
climbing significantly as we close in on
the 2018 midterms which are just over a
year away incredibly so a few things
number one midterms Jenner
we are good for the party not in control
of the White House right that's a
historically underlying systemic thing
so that already sort of says to us well
Democrats should do well in 2018 now
aside from that there's the specifics of
the Trump effect and I've said it before
and I will say it again
this should be a gimme this should be a
gimme in 2018 and in 2020 but the 2016
presidential election also should have
been a gimme and the Democrats managed
to royally screw it up at multiple
levels please don't mess this up build
an actual progressive platform figure
out the best way to focus resources is
it primary demographic Republican seats
and by the way please fight as underdogs
do not fight 2018 and 2020 as entitled
candidates that should obviously win
because of Trump you've got to be right
on the issues as well
Democrats need to get way more
progressive when it comes to their
public platform I've talked about
Medicare for all we've got Bernie +12
co-sponsors plus some other supporters
or whatever the numbers are there is no
reason that Republicans should control
the White House and the House and the
Senate and still fail to take out
Obamacare that signals weakness Pat
particularly on the issues we know that
when Americans are fairly polled they
are way to the left of the elected
officials that represent them and yet
stuff like it's a government socialist
takeover of health care that type of
garbage still works and I I'm begging
and pleading with Democrats don't screw
this up in 2018 there definitely are
some signs of hope on the state level
but if you look at the federal level
since Trump won the election it hasn't
really been so hopeful because there
were four members who were former
congressman who went to Trump's cabinet
Tom Price Mick Mulvaney Brian Zinke and
Mike Pompeo and even though they were in
conservative seats you'd think that the
Democratic challenger would have some
chance I mean given that Trump was so
unpopular yeah and yet they all lost I
mean one of the Republican contenders
Greg G and forte
body-slammed a reporter and he wants to
pull it off couple thoughts on that yet
you're right they did lose the
Democratic challengers were
over-performing Hillary Clinton and most
of those races which is still part of
the trend they are really really red
districts and also Trump was not nearly
as unpopular when those took place as he
is now so I still think that there is
hope here but yeah you're right as I
mentioned at the beginning of the story
at the federal level some of these
special elections have not gone
particularly well I think that the major
primary issue is turnout right that's
the opportunity take some progressive
positions grow a backbone and say we're
actually going to be a left wing party
of course a lot of the Democrats aren't
actually left-wing so that'll probably
be a stumbling block but let's pretend
for a second that they do that half the
country didn't vote in the presidential
election in midterms turnout is usually
even lower from a mathematical
standpoint what that means is every
person who is unregistered that you can
get to come out and vote has even more
of a potential impact than in a
presidential election the lower the
turnout is the more each additional vote
matters and Democrats need to be focused
on voter turnout they need to be
appealing to the unregistered voters in
red states who would vote for Democrats
if they thought Democrats had a chance
who would vote at all if they thought
that there was actually a difference
between the Democrat and the Republican
on many issues there is no difference on
many important issues there is a
difference and if they thought that it
would make a difference then they would
actually come out and vote I I sound
like I'm totally desperate here and it's
because I am I mean 2016 was a pathetic
embarrassment and I'm increasingly
worried the exact same thing is gonna
happen in 2018 it does have to do with
ground game and and that starts with the
DNC I mean you take a look at the most
recent election Hillary Clinton did win
the popular vote by three billion yes
you didn't put her assets in the right
place as to win the states that she
needed yeah and then often times how
many times have we seen it that the
Democrats overall in the country got the
majority of votes when it comes to the
House and Senate seats but because of
the way his districts have been
gerrymandered and just because of how
states are divided up they lost seats
overall it's happened time and again and
I think the assets in the right place
thing is relevant also when we think
about
and this is a serious question to be to
be asking given the circumstances right
I am NOT saying it's not ever worth
primary conservative Democrats given the
circumstances of the situation today and
under Trump does it make sense to focus
limited 20:18 resources on primary mccr
ATS or does it make more sense to focus
on taking Republican seats think about
it
Democrats I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
tell me what you think about all this
new sponsor today for the David Pakman
show today's episode made possible by
Blue Sky binary a forex trading is a
huge space millions of traitors around
the world 80% of those traders lose
money in forex and usually it's some
combination of lacking the appropriate
knowledge maybe relying on others like
traders or auto trading platforms
instead of themselves getting emotional
taking big risks maybe not following
proper money management rules and blue
sky binary offers their education course
and they are a leading financial
education and tech company specifically
focused on forex they've got senior
traders with actual trading experience
and they offer a really well structured
and self-paced course in forex to help
with all of the above the course
includes video on-demand online tests
one-to-one sessions and access to their
community of traders to exchange
knowledge and experience and our viewers
and listeners can get a one-week free
trial at blue sky binary.com / David not
only does it include access to their
training platform but also you get a
session with a senior trader to go over
the basics of forex trading afterwards
it is $99.99 a month if you want to
continue you can stop and resume at any
point
check it out blue sky binary.com /d AV
ID